what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and no
i am not joking around with my title
today
tom cruise could be entering the mcu as
iron man now lately marvel studios has
pretty much
opened back up started production on a
lot of their halted projects because of
the pandemic and we've been getting a
lot of new content lately
including the one division trailer which
was pretty wacky and crazy however
this new report that is coming from a
pretty credible source is even more
crazy but according to this report the
way marvel is thinking about doing this
is not exactly the way that you would
think they would and it's actually kind
of funny and
ironic on marvel studios part as well
but
tom cruise isn't the only super famous
actor that could be getting a cameo in
the mcu very soon
but don't worry i'll break down
everything that you need to know in this
video including the reason why i think
they should actually do this
this week's giveaway is a scarlet witch
funko pop so be sure to subscribe so you
can enter and so you can stay up to date
on all things relating to the mcu
so doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is quite possibly one of the
biggest films and most
important films coming not only to phase
4 but to the
mcu in general and the reason of course
is because it's going to introduce the
multiverse
yes we're going to see a tiny bit of
this in one division but that's really
just going to be her
creating these different realities but
in multiverse of madness
it's going to be blown wide open the
multiverse is officially going to be a
part of the mcu at that point in time
and apparently this is what is going to
bring tom cruise
into the mcu as iron man and doctor
strange in the multiverse
of madness so this report is coming from
daniel richmond who has a pretty good
track record when it comes to leaks
and according to his report he says
marvel is toying with the idea
of doing some high-profile cameos in
this film
and one of those is apparently having an
iron man
from an alternate universe and have him
played by tom cruise
now this report at first may seem simple
but there's actually a lot more to this
that meets the eye
for starters this is playing off another
rumor that we heard not too long ago
about multiverse of madness
the report says that in multiverse of
madness marvel studios is going to have
different versions of characters that we
already know
played by different actors alternate
versions these will of course
come from different realities that will
be explored as the multiverse is burst
open
in doctor strange 2. and apparently in
one of these realities we are going to
see an iron man
tony stark played by tom cruise now as i
mentioned before this is kind of funny
and a little bit ironic because if you
didn't know
back in 1998 tom cruise actually wanted
to produce an iron man movie and not
only did he want to produce the movie
but he wanted to star in it as well
as tony stark iron man now of course
this clearly didn't happen
tom cruise is not iron man iron man
didn't have a movie in 1998
but tom cruise wanted to make it happen
that means he talked to people at marvel
about producing the film
and now he may not have a chance to
produce an iron man movie but he may
have the chance to play iron man
now this would be pretty cool to see
because he wouldn't be taking the place
of the tony stark that we know and love
from our main
mcu timeline he'd be playing an iron man
from a different universe one that
wouldn't be sticking around too long in
our universe but would simply have a
cameo
so the fact that marvel studios wants
alternate versions of some of the heroes
that we already know
and have in our main mcu timeline means
that we could see some pretty crazy
things and the one crazy thing
that everybody wants to see that seems
very very possible right now
is toby maguire spider-man making a
cameo in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and
in the mcu the report that marvel
studios wants alternate versions of
characters that we know in multiverse of
madness combined with the fact that sam
raimi the director of the original
spider-man trilogy with tobey maguire is
now the director of doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
it's the perfect opportunity for us to
get some pizza time
pizza time and for us to potentially get
that classic spider-man meme where
spider-man is pointing at himself but
marvel studios could take this
even further it actually opens up a huge
possibility to do something truly
hilarious
they could have the alternate versions
of the characters that we know be the
people who also
auditioned for the roles before they
went to the current actors for example
with thor and loki
tom hiddleston originally auditioned for
the role of thor
now of course and thankfully he didn't
get the role because he is a perfect
loki and chris hemsworth is a perfect
thor but it doesn't mean that there's
not
an alternate reality in which loki is
thor or at least tom hiddleston is thor
the same goes for john krasinski and
emily blunt now of course by now i'm
sure many of you have heard the rumors
that john krasinski and emily blunt who
are married have met with marvel studios
emily blunt reportedly met with marvel
studios while filming disney's jungle
cruise which of course is owned by
disney which owns marvel
and krazynski apparently had a zoom
meeting with people over at marvel
studios
during the pandemic now of course many
people want them to be playing mr
fantastic
and the invisible woman but what if
marvel really wants them just to play
alternate versions of characters in
multiverse of madness
you see john krasinski and emily blunt
actually auditioned for marvel roles
krasinski auditioned for the role of
captain america
of course chris evans went on to get
that role thankfully
he's perfect and emily blunt actually
was supposed to be
the original black widow marvel studios
actually
wanted emily blunt to play black widow
but unfortunately for her
she was under contractual obligations
with 20th century fox at the time but
again we're all grateful of this not
because we don't like emily blunt but
because we love scarlett johansson
but what if in multiverse of madness the
alternate versions of captain america
and black widow are john krasinski as
captain america
and emily blunt as black widow for the
really deep marvel fans who knew john
krasinski auditioned for captain america
and knew emily blunt was actually
supposed to be black widow
this would be truly hilarious and would
be a pretty brilliant move on marvel's
part
heck zachary levi even auditioned for
the role of star lord of course he's now
shazam
but if he was able to do a cameo in a
marvel film
that would actually be pretty cool now
of course it would be awesome to see all
of these different actors play alternate
versions of the characters that we know
and love
especially since they're going to be
just cameos and not actually replacing
anybody but the real
important setup here for multiverse of
madness with
involving all of these alternate
versions of characters is going to be
the teaser and setup for avengers
secret wars secret wars is what
everybody is expecting the next avengers
in-game level event to be
it's a major story from the comics where
a bunch of different universes
actually collide and become one universe
and what happens is you see many
different versions of the same character
all together so we could have a couple
of different captain americas fighting
together a couple of different iron mans
a few different thors the possibilities
are
truly endless but the first glimpse that
we're going to see of this in the mcu is
going to be in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
so really this is going to be a huge and
very important movie for marvel's phase
4.
it's pretty much going to set up the
next 10 plus years of the mcu
and not to mention it could be how the
x-men possibly come into the mcu as well
but that's a video for another day
be sure to subscribe for more marvel and
dc content so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos and in the meantime
let me know what you think in the
comments down below about tom cruise
possibly making a
cameo as iron man also let me know who
you would just
absolutely love to see make a brief
cameo in the mcu as an alternate version
of one of these favorite characters that
we know and love
let me know who you would choose to
appear in multiverse of madness in the
comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof